هو ليس بالوقت السعيد الذي يقضيه هؤلاء
الاطفال في لعب كره القدم بل هو محاوله
لتمرير وقت الدراسه التي منعوا عنها منذ
اسابيع بعد قرار وزير التربيه بوقف
التعليم السوريين بسبب اضراب الاساتذه
[موسيقى]
يتحدث معنا عن طموحه المستقبلي بعقل ساهم
في نضره الالم والحرمان الذي يعيشه كل
اللاجئين السوريين
انه يسافر
اعتبر يعني اللي بده يطلع مثلا بدي اطلع
ضابط اذا مدرسه
المدارس الرسميه لعدم زياده رواتبهم في ظل
الازمه الاقتصاديه دفع بوزير التربيه الى
الاعلان عن توقف التعليم بعد الظهر لغير
اللبنانيين
حوالي 270 الف طالب سوري في مدارس لبنان
الرسميه اوقفوا عن الدراسه بسبب قراري
وزاره التربيه مره جديده يدفعونها فواتير
غيرهم على حسابي مستقبلهم
تواصلنا مع الوزاره لسؤالي عن هذا القرار
الذي اعتبره الكثيرون عنصريا الا انها
رفضت التعليق لكن مدير مكتب الوزير كان
صرح سابقا بالقول لا يجوز ان لا يتعلم
ابناؤنا وان يتعلم اولاد غيرنا
نقدر انه نحن كشعب عنده معاناه انه عندنا
معاناتنا ولكن نحن بنرفض انه نحن يستغلون
اموال
اليوم المعنيين بلبنان هن بسبب الازمه
رئيس الحكومي وزير المال وزير التربيه
والمعني الاول وزير التربيه لانه اليوم كل
القطاع التعليم واقف بدل ما يطالب وزير
الماليه ورئيس الحكومي بالافراج عن الهبات
والقروض التي قدمت بيتجه
للعربيه الى ان اجتماعات المتوسطه تجري مع
المعانيين في الدوله اللبنانيه لحل هذه
الازمه رجعها ذلك خلال ايام
حتى فتحي ابواب المدارس يلقى الطلاب
السوريون واللبنانيون ايضا
رهائن الابتزاز الماليه الفاضح ناهد يوسف
العربيه بيروت